when you're hanging out in the rock and
roll world now you worked with bowie
yeah and you worked with you worked with
jagger yes
you know paul mccartney you work with
michael jackson yeah i work with dylan
dylan but yeah what was that when did
you work with dave that was i
i opened for him on the first album
he seems unapproachable to me you know
what a lot of people say that and i know
that that's a fact
he's always been really cool to me and
we still
stay in touch you know he played he
played in paris a couple years ago and
called me up came to my house and hung
out and explained this to me because i
still have trouble with it yeah
when you say dylan came to your house
and hung out what do you sit there and
talk about is it about music
um what's interesting we we sat in the
house for a little while and then he
decided he wanted to take a walk
and it was raining but i was like bob
dylan wants to go for a walk it could be
[ __ ] snowing
right let's go so we walked around paris
in the rain and talked about politics
obama um
real estate family um
you know so he's music uh yeah so
when does dylan call you up in paris and
say i heard you were in town
in town let's i want to hang out with
you and you say why don't you come on
over
yeah you serve them dinner no we didn't
we didn't eat you didn't eat we just
hung out and took a walk
how long does the actual hanging out
last it's about three hours
three hours yeah because he had a show
the next day so
do you ever say hey let's jam or do you
ever we've talked about it but we
haven't done it yet i've invited him to
the bahamas to come make a record
who ends the conversation in other words
you're walking around in the rain for
three
hours right do you ever think gee i'm
going to get a [ __ ] cold or you don't
care
i was like i don't you know i don't like
walking in the rain when it's
cold yeah and there's someone bro i got
to do my gigs too
are there umbrellas involved not an
umbrella in sight no and you have nice
clothes
and then we and then we sat on a park
bench in the rain yeah
is he is that you can't possibly lenny
not say to yourself this is [ __ ]
weird i'm soaking wet in the rain for
three hours you know
i have to turn into the 12 year old
lenny
and say man i'm walking and talking with
bob dylan
he's going to wind up on one level he's
villainously saying to himself can i get
him to what can i get him to do yeah
maybe it's candid camera he's fine
get this guy to walk yeah do you think
he's [ __ ] with you at all yeah
it's not possible i don't know because
you know what it's like to be wet in
your clothes
i think he just likes to get out and be
in the world i mean i i heard
somewhere in the states recently or a
year ago or whatever
he got stopped had no id the cops took
him in
he said i'm bob dylan they were like
yeah right right so am i and
uh then they found out he was and is
that the last interaction
do you guys email each other when i was
uh
i was in atlanta doing the catching fire
movie and he played in atlanta i went to
the gig
and um saw him afterwards he gave me his
harmonica
wow are you kidding me what do you do
with that harmonica do you display it i
put it away man
where do you put it do you display i
have it in this thing where i carry like
my some of my jewelry
yeah and i you know i just have it like
a box that you have jewelry in yeah
there's the harmonica when you open it
up it gives you that feeling oh my god
this is bob dylan
has a piece of uh masking tape on it
with the key
you know that it's in and yeah